[Music]
as a realist I'm not naive about the
world it can be a dangerous place and
that's one of the reasons why we have to
have a strong national defense and it
sometimes means we have to actually use
our military power against other
countries and other organizations that
might threaten us or that have attacked
us that's the reality of the world but
we really do need to think about a
foreign policy that is careful to focus
on our interests and is cognizant of
those human costs and I think that it
isn't being mushy headed to say look
there are people real people harmed by
our activities you can think about those
soldiers killed overseas now it's one
thing if they're killed in a war like
World War 2 a war that was necessary for
America to fight for its safety against
a really bad regime like Nazi Germany
and another thing to think about a
situation where we're trying to engage
in regime change against a country that
offers very little threat to the United
States and maybe a bad regime like in
the case of Saddam Hussein's Iraq but a
regime that has not directly attacked us
and it's not necessarily a threat to
core American interests and we need to
think hard about what those costs would
be in that situation and the human costs
are quite powerful and we can see that
here in America if you visit a military
hospital and you can see people who have
lost limbs or you could see it in in
communities where there are people
suffering from things like PTSD that are
less obvious to the eye but you also see
it downrange and oftentimes we'd read
the newspaper and it says three American
soldiers killed here or there but those
are people with families that care about
them parents who love them we need to
think about that and to make sure that
if you're going to ask people to make
that ultimate sacrifice that they're not
doing so in vain that there is a real
sense of the urgency about why we need
to do this it tears up to our safety
it's necessary to do so there are the
other alternatives in the toolkit of
statecraft have been
exhausted and that you have an
understanding of how to prosecute that
conflict and how to get out so that
we're not just endlessly expending money
and people's lives in something that
isn't working and so we need leaders to
think about those things and to
recognize that and you know one of the
things that that I would recommend is
you know you go over to the newer parts
of of Arlington Cemetery and you can see
that cost and again if that cost is
worth paying because it's necessary I
understand you know my grandfather
fought in World War two he was wounded
in action was captured by the Germans
and sent to a Pheo w camp and he
suffered from his experience there
throughout his life well that's a cost
that was worth paying and lots of people
hundreds of thousands of people suffered
far more than my grandfather did they
gave the ultimate sacrifice but for a
war of choice a war that tears up to
some idealistic goal that's unrealizable
we really need to think hard about those
costs I think about Vietnam and a lot of
people are worth watching the
documentary series and you see some of
the really bad ideas and bad incentives
involved in the prosecution of that war
and you really feel for the 58,000
American lives that were lost there and
the hundreds of thousands of lives lost
innocent lives lost throughout the
Vietnamese country whether in the north
or the south and it's just
heart-wrenching but it's no different
when it's on a smaller scale when it's a
place like a rock or a place like Libya
and unfortunately the United States did
not lose a lot of people in Libya but
the fact is is we've created a situation
that has a cost there as well and again
presidents and Congress need to think
primarily about America's interests but
when we're trying to help people abroad
you need to think about what the
consequences are going to be for those
who are ostensibly trying to help and
oftentimes that has led to bad results
so in general over the last 15 to 25
years our foreign policy simply isn't
working it is not making us safer and
that's why we need to reconsider what
we're doing we need to rethink our grand
strategy we need to rethink how we're
using
diplomacy and economic levers of
statecraft we need to rethink our
budgets and the types of platforms we're
building and the types of missions we
want to send our troops on this is
vitally important so that we can right
size the military for the challenges
ahead and I don't think we're doing that
which is why we need to bring new voices
into the conversation the other thing I
think that we should ask for is we would
I think we would like our executives to
practice humility that means that they
need to understand what they don't know
and to have that be part of the
decision-making process sure we can talk
about well we're not sure what would
happen but we have to plan for it sure
but if you're really having to plan for
so many things based on assumptions upon
assumptions upon assumptions you can
have a situation in which you can't
actually satisfy the conditions for
success except in theory an approach
that is focused on greater realism and
more Prudential ism in our foreign
policy does not mean that the United
States should abandon the world the
United States needs to be engaged abroad
in terms of trading with other countries
providing positive some outcomes between
people's diplomacy cultural engagement
people-to-people engagement we can be
engaged in the world and open to the
world without thinking that the United
States needs to be everywhere and
without the United States having to lead
and be militarily deployed to every part
of the globe so that's really important
that we not throw the baby out with the
bathwater if the United States can be
engaged internationally it can avoid
xenophobia or isolation without
spreading American democracy say through
the sword or being forward-deployed in
so many parts of the world and trying to
be deeply engaged in all kinds of local
conflicts in every part of the world
[Music]